wednesday edition of pro football talk
live on tuesday's chris sims unbuttoned
chris sims who else unveiled his top
five quarterback prospects if you're
watching on nbcsn you see the graphic
joe burrow number one justin herbert
number two jordan love number three
tuatanga valoa number four what gives
sims jacob easton number five that that
you know surely the biggest reaction is
going to come from the placement of
tonga by law at number four some people
still have him penciled in as the fifth
overall pick in the draft by the miami
dolphins why did you put him at number
four
well listen i i like tua there's a lot
to like i mean yes you know is you know
accurate thrower you know good athlete
can move in the pocket certainly you
know makes good decisions and not a guy
that's going to throw in a lot of
interceptions sees the field well okay
all that but i'm not necessarily sure
sitting here
going ooh the way he plays the style of
play is going to translate to the nfl
you know he's fast but he's not real
fast and you know if anybody watched the
pod just in the segment before you know
he his size is an issue to me yes his
injury history is an issue to me but
size ability to throw in the pocket with
people around him make big throws down
the middle of the field with lyman in
his face you're not going to see that
you know and it's a good arm but it's
not a great arm and you know again i
think you got to be careful when you
watch alabama it's a very good offense
schematically and it's got the best some
of the best talent you're going to find
i mean mike all three of their receivers
that they throw to like i said two were
going in the top 25 this year the other
kid number six is going to be a top 20
pick next year you know there's a lot of
talent around him but the size and
injury history certainly is going to
make me dock him a little bit let alone
mike how many plays i watch on film
where the play is over and i go wait did
he get hurt is he hurt i mean there's
just so many it's almost like he has a
hard time getting out of danger's way
that would concern me to pick him at
number five man that would be risky i'm
just not so sure you know i thought i
wouldn't feel comfortable with that as a
gm
and when he suffered the hip injury
during the season i canvassed between 10
and 15 general managers to get an idea
of how this would affect him and the
comments from one still resonate with me
today the idea that he had three lower
body injuries at the college level it is
a bigger faster more intense game of
football when you come to the nfl level
you throw in the fact that he does have
these plays where he didn't get out of
harm's way he got hit look it's a basic
matter of physics and
uh uh what what else uh i'm i'm yeah
physics and physics
no the more you get hit the more you get
hit the more you're going to get hurt
that's how it works so you have to find
a way to minimize those hits and if
you're going to have those hits every
game where people stop and say is he
going to get up
at the nfl level you're not going to get
up more frequently than you don't get up
at the college level it's that simple
you got to incorporate into the game
getting out of bounds hitting the deck
understanding how your body operates in
space with the other bodies around you
and it's funny and of all people chris
the check down account which is operated
by the nfl had a highlight clip that it
put out last night of peyton manning
doing bootlegs and the one thing peyton
manning knew better than anything else
is where his body was in relation to
everyone else's and he knew
instinctively when to get down when to
slide when to fall when to avoid taking
the hit because the more hits you take
the more likely you're going to be hurt
and not be able to play for your team
you're hitting on something very
important here no pun intended tua takes
those hits and he's fearless about it
but the problem is at the next level
he's going to be not playing more often
than he is playing if he keeps taking
those hits no doubt and again this isn't
about what you watch on film right now i
mean if you just evaluate the film from
what it is right i mean yeah two is the
second best watch there is because the
offense is wide open and he's got talent
around him and he throws from a perfect
pocket all the time but the reality is
nfl is not like that it's not maybe two
or three quarterbacks in the league get
that type of protection he plays very
small and because of that and the the
fact that you know you just mentioned he
gets swallowed up in the pocket at times
it leads him to dance around try to make
plays escape the pocket all of those
things he got away with that a little
bit in college certainly and he was
capable of making some plays but we saw
yeah he got swallowed up and hit a whole
bunch of times with the law of physics
like you're talking about and to i just
don't think that style of play is going
to translate to the nfl you know it's a
little bit like i and i want to say this
i like tua he's a lefty i'm rooting for
him again this is just my honest
evaluation but i'll go back to somebody
like johnny manziel oh yeah he was
scrambling all around in college
football
yeah that was great he got to the nfl
and every defensive end ran 4-4 or 4-5
and all of a sudden you realize damn i
can't do the stuff i did in college i'm
going to have to sit here in the pocket
and make big throws with people around
me i mean the people we see run in the
nfl they it's lamar jackson he runs 4-2
or 4-3 i mean that that's the special
that's the type of speed you have to
have to make it as a runner in the
league and those are the things that
concerned me about to it there's a lot
to like i get it but i think there's a
huge risk factor here and i think
compared to jordan love justin herbert
and uh burro that yeah i think his game
projects uh the the least to the nfl as
compared to those three ahead of them
that i got
let's talk about justin herbert we
interviewed him at the scouting combine
before you
uh
uh uh how do i put it delicately
one thing real quick just before you hit
that because two also look at kyler
murray and this is the comment i wanted
to make sorry mike the kyler murray
right you look at him and go well he's
another guy 4-3 we didn't see a ton of
highlights of him just scrambling all
over the field last year why because
it's a different animal in the nfl and
kylo murray would blow two away in a
40-yard dash so if he's not going to be
able to run around and do some of the
magic we saw in college i certainly
don't think a guy who i'm going to say
tua runs a mid to high four six is going
to be running around making plays off
schedule like that either
okay back to herbert we talked that's
fine we talked him at the scouting
combine you've got him at number two
look i don't know that i would put him
at number two simply because he idolized
joey harrington growing up to me that's
the biggest red flag that i've seen in a
top quarterback in years sorry justin
i'm just giving you my honest evaluation
here you have a more meaningful
evaluation than whether or not he was a
joey harrington fan what caused you to
put him at number two
but mike your point there is still
something that's scaring nfl teams about
justin herbert and i get it the fact
that he hasn't been outside of eugene
oregon how much does he love football
because he had a chance to come out last
year and be you know probably a top 10
pick but he stayed in school you know so
those are the things that concern people
but the talent is off the level uh off
you know it's what do i want to say the
talent is off the charts thank you uh
for justin herbert i mean first off he
has the best arm in the draft he can
make game giant changing wow type throws
where you just go whoa like there's just
not too many people on the planet that
could have fit that ball in there and
that is going to lead to great design
like you know don't tell me you know arm
strength is not important i'm so sick of
hearing about that patrick mahomes is
who he is because his arm is really
strong aaron rodgers is who he is i'm
not saying it's the only thing but it's
a great tool for all the great
quarterbacks we've ever seen most of
them had pretty damn strong arms and
that's herbert is a different level of
thrower he's a big person he could throw
with people around him and make those
20-yard out route throws with people
holding on in his shoulders and he can
do it with ease he's a phenomenal
athlete i would say when he gets going
and opens up he's the fastest
quarterback of everybody uh or
this top five and then added to that
you know when you look at his struggles
the film's not always clean mike but a
lot of the things i didn't like about
the negative plays on film were
were related to the offense not just in
herbert and that's where i think all
evaluators we got to be careful
sometimes we take the offense and
everything that goes on and give the
credit or the blame to the quarterback
and i just want to say listen if you put
jordan love or justin herber in alabama
and if you don't think they would have
had unbelievable stats and the game
would have looked a whole lot easier
then you're just crazy you know tua had
the advantage of being coached by the
greatest college coach ever with great
talent around him so yeah his game is a
little cleaner maybe he's ready to go
for some of the nuances of the
quarterback position but top end see you
know highest ceiling type talent yeah i
think justin herbert probably has the
highest ceiling at anybody in this draft
at the quarterback position
and that's what concerns me about tua
back to him for a second when you have
so much great talent around you
maybe you get a skewed representation of
how good of a quarterback a guy is
because
the la the linemen are winning on every
play with their blocks you're getting a
great running game because your running
back is blasting through the defense
your receivers are getting open it's not
the same adversity across the board
which makes it easier for the
quarterback and now at the next level
everything gets tougher it's tougher for
the quarterback it's tougher for all of
his teammates the windows are narrower
the opportunities are fewer and farther
between that's going to be one of the
challenges and look as it relates to
justin herbert and that oregon focus
i
i think there's a positive there as well
because wherever he goes
football's going to be all he has that
you know that's going to be your refuge
that becomes your bubble and that's all
you do you throw yourself into it you're
at work you go early you stay late
you're used to being in a restricted
right a restricted range of movement so
it's from the house to the facility back
to the house to the facility and it's
work and it's work and it's worked and i
think maybe that'll help him in a weird
sort of way as long as he has the
emotional support in place maybe his
parents you know travel to wherever it
is and get an apartment or a house or
live with him wherever he is to help him
make that transition but i think there
are ways to do it there's been enough
guys who have had to do it there's
enough case studies out there that i
think if the whoever takes them if it's
the dolphins at five or someone else i
think if they're smart they'll find a
way to make this transition without it
causing him to collapse
yeah no doubt about it i i that that's a
really good point by you mike it is and
you're right if you you know again this
is where meeting the player is going to
come in handy and i don't know if that's
going to happen here this year but
that's the thing you want to get a feel
for right because then you can go okay
this kid's a good kid he loves football
yes so what he doesn't he hasn't been
around the world or the country he
doesn't care he just wants to play
football go home hang out and that's it
and there's some positives in that and
mike back to your tool point with the
team around them listen that's why i
my evaluation on daniel jones was wrong
last year if i had to self-scout myself
like you know i do and two quarterbacks
jump out to me daniel jones and dak
prescott and i think i i looked at those
two quarterbacks when i evaluated them
and put too much of the blame on them
for team and offensive issues you know
dak prescott yeah he walked on the field
in the sec and he was on the lesser team
almost every game he was in and then we
didn't see any receivers from
mississippi state coming out in the nfl
draft you know so therefore there was
moments in games where it didn't look
real pretty and i put that blame on dak
prescott where i should have said well
there was nobody open the protection
wasn't that great he was clearly on the
the far worst team on the field that day
and that's where we all got to be
careful because yes it's going to look
really pretty from two of us sometimes
but again to my to my point originally
you put herbert or jordan love there in
alabama their film would look a whole
lot pretty you put tua at utah state and
make him play and that offense was i
would he would throw more interceptions
he would have more mistakes in his game
there's less talent there's less
creativity in the scheme and i think
that's part of the evaluation process
with these quarterbacks
we'll have plenty of time over the next
29 days as the draft approach is to talk
about the other quarterbacks joe burrow
jordan love jacob easton let me ask you
this though before we take a break
what's the gap between eason at five and
your next guy at number six
uh it's it's so i think there's a
significant gap between the top four and
then that number five guy and then eason
yeah it's not a huge gap you know the
next group of guys with the jalen hurts
and you know uh from from georgia you
know uh there's the kid from florida
atlantic i like so i would say there's a
little bit of a gap yes because easton
has a chance in my opinion to be a
starting quarterback maybe in the nfl at
some point i'm not going to sit here and
tell you i love him the guys i look
after him i i want to sit there and go
other than jalen hurts who has potential
and a work in progress the rest of them
i go i think these are career backup
guys guys who could be you know top tier
backups but never franchise starting
quarterbacks
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports